namur en belgique situé au confluent de
la cendre et de la meuse et depuis 1986
et la capitale de la wallonie d'ici par
l'un des nombreux chemins qui mènent à
saint jacques de compostelle comme les
pèlerins nous emprunterons ce chemin
afin de regagner reims et sa cathédrale
nous passerons par les ardennes belges
et françaises pour arriver en champagne
un prétexte fait de rencontres et de
lieux qui font tout le charme de ce long
chemin de randonnée appelé aussi le gr
on dit les namur les gens sont lents
d'ailleurs le symbole de la ville
c'est l'escargot c'est sciemment que les
namurois l'ont choisi mais s'ils sont
lents distille ses pour permettre aux
autres de les suivre
on raconte même que c'est à namur que
l'on aurait inventé la frite
nous prenons le départ et en flânant au
hasard des rues du vieux namur on
ressent une douceur de vivre cher aux
namurois au milieu des pas et des
coquilles saint jacques
nous sommes sur le bon chemin c'est sous
le regard de la citadelle surplombant la
ville que nous quittons un mur
nous pas nous emmène à profondeville au
bord de la meuse le but d'abord et de ne
pas se perdre dans le dédale de petites
rues de ce charmant village
puis derrière les montagnes de la haute
meuse nous découvrons les jardins
d'annevoie ou lot de trois sources au
jaillissant aucune machinerie depuis
plus de 250 ans un lieu magique très
visité
françois grâce à la pureté de ses
sources et leur température constante
élèves des truites arc en ciel on peut
même les pêchés dans les temps il y en a
toujours car françois peut compter sur
un stock de six mille tweets élevé dans
ces bassins
une fois la taille et le poil tant elles
sont bonnes pour la table et
saint-françois l'essai d'un seul coup
d'oeil
alors ça c'est le plus gros de mon
travail
trier le poisson l'idéal c'est que le
poisson sorte d'ici que ce soit pour le
fumoir où que ce soit pour la
commercialisation autour de 380 grammes
voilà ça c'est une truite qui fait à peu
près de 380 grammes et c'est du poisson
à partir de l'un d'eux l'éclosion qui a
entre 14 et 17 mois ça ça à la longueur
mais c'est un peu trop maigre donc ça
grossit sa poule
et puis arrive l'heure du repas
détruites elles sont nourries avec des
granulés composé entre autres de farine
de poisson de blé et de maïs
ce qui n'a pas l'air de leur déplaire
les truites qui sont dans ce bassin là
c'est du poisson qui fait à partir de un
kilo et demi jusqu'à 4 kg
la truite est un poisson à croissance
continue aussi longtemps qu'elle va
trouver à manger
elle va grossir une truite ça peut vivre
trente ans quand même 25 30 ans dans la
nature une truite de 10 kg c'est
relativement classique la truite la plus
grosse que j'ai mangé à mettre 27 16 kg
on a mangé à 18,2 sud
c'est sur cette incroyable anecdote que
nous reprenons notre chemin pour
regagner la meuse et dinan
cette petite ville connue autrefois pour
ces artisans habiles à travailler le
cuivre et le letton a vu naître un
personnage qui a marqué à jamais le
monde de la musique
le créateur du saxophone adolphe sax
marc est l'initiateur de nombreux
événements artistiques à dinan toujours
autour du saxophone
en historien amateur la vie de ce génie
n'a pas de secret pour lui dans le sac
sans fait c'est le fils d'un facteur
d'instruments qui est installé à dinan
qui est un passionné évidemment musique
qui inventent qu'ils perfectionnent et
le gamin il est dans l'atelier donc sans
arrêt il essaie de donner un coup de
main son père il est manifestement doué
donc il va très vite devenir un
excellent d'ouvriers est aussi très
rapidement un inventeur ce gamin va donc
que perfectionner avec son père pas mal
d'instruments et le succès étant tél
ils vont hélas quitté dit non mais pour
s'installer à bruxelles ou à dos le sax
va finir par inventer une famille
d'instruments la famille notamment du
saxophone
à cette époque l'armée française décide
de former des harmonies pour ces soldats
qui s'ennuient aux frontières adolphe
sax remporté l'appel d'offres et fournit
donc l'armée alors que la grande musique
le boudent les soldats français seront
les premiers à jouer avec ses sex fun
donc les américains reprennent l'idée en
fait d'équiper leurs régiments qui sont
là en bordure entre le nord et le sud au
terme de la guerre de sécession
il équipe les régiments de musique et
après un certain nombre d'années on
abandonne le matériel dans ce qu'on
appelle encore aujourd'hui quand les
américains quittent les endroits le
stock américain et donc tout est mis en
vente d'une manière assez bon marché et
c'est là en fait que les noirs
américains les les inventeurs du jazz
mais qui est une musique d'abord chanter
c'est la voix qui domine dans cette
musique particulière qui vont découvrir
cet instrument qui est reconnu comme le
violoncelle comme étant le plus proche
de la brouille man et donc ils vont se
l'approprier particulièrement ténor pour
l'utiliser dans cette musique magnifique
qu'est le jazz et grâce au jazz le
saxophone va finalement gagné l'europe
et conquérir l'europe peu à peu et ce
n'est que bien plus tard un film
avant que la musique classique va
récupérer à nouveau cet instrument qui
avait été pensée aussi pour elle nous
prenons la direction de la maison de
monsieur saxe cette maison qui a vu
naître adolphe sax est aujourd'hui
ouverte au public qui peut tout savoir
des créations de ce génial inventeur
patinant autre niveau pour les cuivres
at-il en belgique était connu pour lady
landry et le cuivre est donc on peut
dire que l'instrument vraiment le
saxophone est un instrument né à dinan
avec les matériaux de dino on peut dire
que la 9-5 a vraiment été celui qui a
qui a apporté beaucoup plus de justesse
à tous les instruments à vent notamment
dans tous les mois on peut pas dire
qu'il ait beaucoup évolué
c'est vrai qu'il y a constamment des
recherches chez les facteurs
d'instruments mais la conception
acoustique est toujours la même il faut
pas nécessairement beaucoup de souffle
avec peu de soufre ont peu joué du
saxophone
nous laissons dinan et ses saxophones
pour gagner un lieu classé patrimoine
majeur de la wallonie le château de
frère situé sur la commune d'hastière au
fin fond des ardennes belges
il n'est pas facile de s'y rendre car la
meuse nous fait barrage pour éviter un
détour de plusieurs kilomètres
nous faisons comme tous les marcheurs
nous enjoignons voile sort un lieu de
villégiature autrefois très prisée et
surtout son passeur d'eau le dernier en
fonction sur la meuse
pas besoin de la plaie des qu'axel vous
voit sur la berge
il vient immédiatement mis à disposition
par la communauté juive et autres on
peut faire 150 traversée par jour c'est
principalement des marcheurs
pour le démarrer ces inconnus une fois
qu'il est bien démarré ce qu'on vous dit
m annonce qu on fait une centaine sous
la journée y a pas de mal à s'endormir
au sort
nous voilà enfin au château de frères
édifié au 14e siècle le plus beau
monument historique de la haute meuse
cette magnifique demeure de style
renaissance ancienne résidence d'été des
duc de beaufort spontin accueilli jadis
des autres royaumes l'intérieur du
château et raffiné cosmopolite il a été
meublée par les vingt générations qui
habitèrent jusqu'à ce jour
un subtil mélange des genres comme dans
cette chapelle avec ses boiseries
régence et son hôtel baroque à
l'extérieur des jardins à la française
avec des oranges et de plus de 300 ans
qui continue de produire sous la
surveillance des bustes inspiré de
figure de jeu de cartes
surplombant ses jardins à trianon et 6
km de labyrinthe
tout cela dans un site naturel une
visite dans un ensemble hors du temps
le gr 654 nous emmène près de nîmes
doucement le décor change nous sommes
maintenant dans le parc naturel vire -
hermes temps là il nous découvrons un
gouffre naturel fait de roche de
calcaire le fonderie des chiens un
endroit atypique ce plateau unique en
belgique attire de nombreux randonneurs
et amoureux de la nature car la bio
diversité
il est exceptionnel camille un agent du
parc est souvent là pour faire découvrir
aux randonneurs cet îlot de nature
préservée dans ce cas particulier c'est
qu'évidemment ici on est sur le calcaire
donc le massif calcaire et en face la
forêt a redonné donc des roches
siliceuses dur est totalement différent
donc ces boisés une forêt pratiquement
fermé de 80% de feu lui tandis qu'ici
c'est le calcaire les pelouses
calcicoles c'est le terme approprié
déconner tu reçois un substrat
géologique calcaire l'euphorie des
chiens en fait c'est un paléo gouffre
dont c'est un gouffre qui s'est formé il
ya très très longtemps alerté resserre
et qui a été on fait rempli par des
sédiments ferrugineux apportées par les
mers chaudes de l'époque donc le trou
était comblé et au moment où les
civilisations sont apparus notamment les
celtes ces gens là se sont rendus compte
qu'en prélevant c'est de terre rouge
foncé brun dans des bas fourneau
parvenait à faire fondre et à obtenir du
dû faire pour construire des armes et
autres
donc ils ont continué à exploiter toute
la cavité les romains et tous les autres
civilisations qui ont suivi hees a
perduré jusqu'au 19ème siècle où on a
même poussé le luxe jusqu'à prélever les
cryan résidus qu'on a trouvé qu'ils
étaient exportées vers les usines de
charleroi pour encore récupéré quelques
pourcents de faire si vous amenez un
botaniste ici vous laisser un petit peu
inventorié vous allez directement
obtenir un ensemble de plantes qui sont
totalement atypique que des espèces
méditerranéennes ou subie l'italienne
donc c'est dû aux conditions
particulières de la pelouse calcicole
son exposition plein sud
un sol très faible très pauvres des très
peu d'eau et la chaleur évidemment et
équitable sur le rocher calcaire
constamment
c'est sous un soleil brûlant que nous
quittons camille et le plateau de
calcaire pour retrouver notre sentier de
randonnée
direction le village dolois sur viroin
notre prochaine étape ici une vieille
spécialité venus d'espagne et adapté par
la famille de philippe depuis des
dizaines d'années fait le bonheur des
marcheurs des touristes de passage
l'escavèche
alors l'escale est surfaite c'est une
vieille méthode de conservation de
poissons dans une sauce qui porte le nom
d' escabèche est une sauce donc à base
de vinaigre mais l'enquêté n'est qu'un
peu de vin blanc de l'eau de la farine
des épices des oignons et du citron
c'est une méthode de conservation qui
nous vient de l'occupation espagnole aux
16e et 17e siècles dans notre région
la matière première utilisée est
détruite
ou alors ce que les gens appellent
traditionnement de l'anguille mais qui
est en fait de l'aiguillât qui est
simplement passé dans la fécule de pomme
de terre puis à la poêle on va le
laisser reposer toute une nuit en
chambre froide lendemain va préparer la
sauce qui porte le nom d'espalais ch
on va disposer des progrès sur les plans
de travail dans lesquelles on va venir
mettre deux morceaux de poisson on
viendra verser la sauce bouillante sur
le poisson 3 les points ci remplit bien
repartir en chambre froide où là avec le
froid les scarlets jeu va se figer et le
troisième jour on va simplement couler
le push paraffine sur le promettent une
feuille d'aluminium et l'étiquette fort
arriver au produit mais vous voyez là
grâce au gré au vinaigre l'escavèche
peut facilement se conserver trois à
quatre mois et autres avantages toutes
les arêtes des poissons refondu le
succès tels que philippe nos villages
même pas d'exporter son espèce
les français préfèrent traverser la
frontière venez ranger une escale esch
très bonne idée passer une journée en
belgique
savard semblent meilleures ici que
plutôt que j'allais l'acheter chez eux
nous quittons alors les ardennes belges
pour la france nous nous joignons un
groupe de randonneurs afin de visiter à
seulement trois kilomètres de la
frontière belge
le premier village sur notre route
rocroi un village étonnant de par sa
construction en étoile édifié en 1555
sous le règne d'henri deux veaux croix
possède un urbanisme concentriques ni
rue partant en rayon d'une place
centrale
ceci pour permettre aux soldats de la
garnison d'accéder le plus rapidement
possible à leur poste
la légende veut que vauban en soi
l'architecte
mais les recherches démontrent qu'il a
juste remanié la forteresse et construit
les fortifications autour des remparts
de terre il existe un autre village
construit de la même manière palmanova
en italie on dit que c'est léonard de
vinci qui serait à l'origine du projet
elfe l'un de ses disciples qui aurait
construit rocroi
le mystère demeure
le village de rocroi est aussi célèbre
pour un autre fait la bataille de rocroi
en mai 1643 en pleine guerre de religion
appelé aussi guerre de trente ans le
jeune duc d'enghien et sa cavalerie
surprennent les forces espagnoles qui
marche sur paris déstabiliser l'armée
espagnole est contrainte à la retraite
on comptera dix mille morts dans cet
affrontement le trône du roi de france
fut sauvée au musée de rocroi diorama
exceptionnel relaxe cette bataille
plus de 2200 figure et nous donne un
aperçu de ce moment son créateur
c'est denis un sculpteur passionné
d'histoire et de peinture enfants il a
toujours aimé jouer avec des petits
soldats est devenu adulte la passion
toujours présente
c'est naturellement qu'il a décidé de
créer les siens denis se définit comme
un miniaturiste et l'on peut dire qu'il
a un certain souci du détail
donc à solennelle mènent tous sont
différents chaque fois c'est une culture
différente
les visages tant les positions changent
à chaque fois c'est une nouvelle
figurine
ils sont uniques là ce sont ces sur une
gravure de jacques callot je prends
toutes les différentes figures in gelé
redessine je les colle sur un morceau de
résine et là je viens les sculpter une
fois j'ai fini la sculpture je passe à
un autre stade c'est le moulage donc je
fais un moule en silicone à partir de la
sculpture ensuite on coule le métal et
ensuite on a la figurine en état d'
reste plus qu'à peindre est là denis va
prendre soin de respecter les couleurs
des vêtements de l'époque sculpter une
figurine nécessite deux heures de
travail et il en faudrait des milliers
de nids pour créer une arme et ses
décors poussé fait naître qu'il
affectionne
des idées pour ses prochains travaux ils
ne manquent pas
j'ai beaucoup d'idées j'ai beaucoup plus
d'idées que de temps pouvoir fournir
nous revenons dans le monde grandeur
nature et notre chemin de pelles rail
nous emmène près du lac des vieilles
forges entourée de forêts et de collines
escarpées le lac des vieilles forges
ressemble un véritable lac canadien il
offre un havre de fraîcheur et de repos
extraordinaire aussi appelé lac de vita
caire il représente la plus grande
étendue d'eau des ardennes françaises
mais notre prochaine étape est plus loin
derrière les forêts seynod village de
signy l'abbaye là dans son jardin nous
rencontrons un personnage pas commun
frédéric un agriculteur qui cultive ses
légumes avec passion
quel plaisir quoi de voir pousser la
plante moi c'est mon c'est mon bol
d'oxygène c'est mon moment de bonheur
mon moment de de détente
on pourra peut-être passer par les
animaux aussi après les animaux ce sont
ces moutons excellent de hollande et ses
belles vaches des blondes d'aquitaine
l'aimé avec frédéric comme le jardin
tout le monde ici est au régime bio tous
ces produits sont destinés à la cuisine
de son auberge
car frédéric est aussi restaurateur cet
ingénieur agronome qui est aujourd'hui
le restaurant familial qui existait déjà
du temps de la révolution à l'auberge
changement de look
frédéric a maintenant la tenue du
restaurateur son plaisir c'est quand ses
clients apprécient la cuisine fait des
produits de sa ferme
même si le succès est là frédéric et sa
femme sophie ont encore beaucoup de
projets on envisage de développer un
atelier port
si ce n'est bio au moins très écolo pur
on a commencé à travailler à faire des
viandes séchées depuis cette année donc
on aimerait bien aussi faire une ferme
de port jusqu'au bout c'est tout ce
genre de challenge tous les ans donne
une petite limite à quelques années on a
passé les deux tiers de notre carton vin
bio ça c'était assez facile très très
agréable on a dégoté des producteurs en
relation directe face et c'est un autre
métier de le fait de vouloir travailler
en proximité et directement avec le
producteur ça nous permet ça nous donne
une autre vision du métier ça coûte un
peu plus cher c'est la main d'oeuvre
mais justement c'est bien ça relocalise
à main d'oeuvre ont fait travailler des
gens du village qui sont ravis de venir
travailler dans ce genre d'ambiance et
pour nous c'est agréable de travailler
justement dans une ambiance de gens sont
heureux de venir travailler chez nous
en cuisine si l'équipe est jeune les
plats servis sont dignes de grands
restaurants rémi le cuisinier nous livre
une des recettes de l'auberge préparé
avec les produits de la ferme
aujourd'hui on va préparer la noisettes
d'agneau lardé au coulis de fève tonka
noisettes d'agneau c'est le filet
d'agneau qu'on a levé du train de côte
qui est ici et du lard fumé donc
l'agneau il est de la ferme familiale et
le lard fumé c'est du lard ardennes de
france consumer nommément je vais couper
trois est d'environ 50 60 grammes
chacune voilà
avec le leurre fumé maison jeuland houle
de dans le lard fumé ça va donner
ça va ça l'est la viande ça donne m qui
vous fumez aussi l agneau la cuisson de
la noisette d'agneau donc à l'huile
d'olive lannion toujours l huile d'olive
2 minutes de chaque côté ont valu
reposer je vais aller un petit son de
légumes courgettes tomates un gâteau en
cocotte poireaux oignons champignons et
un tout mandat avec carottes au cumin
donc là c'est le cool fm
de maistre la brochette de noisettes sur
le critère de l'estragon et de la
mélisse mon pareil c'est les herbes
qu'on a dans le jardin au pied un peu de
pop et coeur pour décorer le tour de
l'assiette
mais voilà après cette belle recette
nous décidons de passer la nuit dans un
lieu insolite dans le bois de
signy-l'abbaye sur le site du chêne
perché en haut des arbres se dressent
des cabanes quatre cabanes différentes
sont aménagés on peut venir en couple ou
en famille et même y passer la nuit
un vrai rêve d'enfant sans électricité
éclairé à lampes à huile nous nous
installons pour dormir
immergé au milieu de la forêt dans ces
cabanes sont volés nous sommes réveillés
par le jour qui se lève et les sons de
la forêt comme nos voisins nous aurons
droit à un copieux petit déjeuner servi
à domicile
la nuit a été paisible car le confort de
ses belles cabane il sans reproche nous
admirons de notre auteur la campagne
ardennaise mais il est temps de
reprendre la route
nous quittons les ardennes à faissault
un sanglier d'acier animal mythique
emblème des ardennes trône au milieu des
champs cette culture réalisé par eric
sléziak mesure près de 10 mètres de haut
14 mètres de long et 5 mètres de large
50 tonnes de métal 6 tonnes de soudure
et 11 ans de travail c'est ce qu'il a
fallu à son créateur pour le faire
naître de son imagination
encore un bout de chemin en champagne
pour rejoindre reims la cité des sacres
qui est la fin de notre parcours
si nous arrivons au terme de notre
voyage compostelle est encore très loin
pour les pèlerins qui s'y rendent
nous rentrons dans la ville par le canal
de l'aisne à la marne emprunté par les
péniches
c'est aussi un lieu de détente pour les
rémois
sur le chemin de la cathédrale une
boutique rose attire notre attention
c'est là que nous trouvons le célèbre
biscuit rose que l'on déguste ici avec
une coupe de champagne
l'un des plus vieux biscuits de
l'histoire culinaire il est toujours
fabriqué à reims et la recette est la
même depuis sa création
c'est un boulanger au xviie siècle qui
colle aura un gâteau avec du carmin pour
en masquer les brins de vanille noir le
mélange avec le blanc initiale du gâteau
le rendit rose et ce fut un succès le
biscuit rose sucré en 1690 et le
champagne en 1770 certains affirment
avec humour que le champagne a été créé
pour accompagner le biscuit rose
nous voilà au terminus de notre chemin
devant la magnifique cathédrale notre
dame de reims a été construite au xiiie
siècle et il s'agit de l'une des
réalisations majeures de l'art gothique
en france tant pour son architecture que
pour sa statuaire qui sous le regard de
jeanne d'arc ne compte pas moins de 2300
trois statuts elle est inscrite à ce
titre au patrimoine mondial de l'unesco
depuis 1991
presque tous les rois de france ont été
sacrés ici ce qui a valu à enfin un
autre nom la cité des sacres
oh
si la cathédrale est très prisée des
touristes
on peut également voir des pèlerins
faire tamponner leur carnet la
credencial attestant leur passage
il nous reste maintenant plus qu'à
admirer l architecture intérieure de la
cathédrale la beauté des nombreux
vitraux dont certains créés par
l'artiste marc chagall sanef sous voûte
de 38 m et tant d'autres oeuvres qui
sont de véritables consentement pour les
yeux
à
mais cela reste un lieu de prière et de
recueillement et après notre long voyage
nous restons plusieurs minutes dans
cette atmosphère apaisante pour nous
ressourcer et penser surtout à nos
prochaines aventures
oh